we don't have a lot of time left
breaking just before the show came on
tonight a huge development the president
referred to it surrounding the non
whistleblower whistleblower his
complaint as we've been saying was a
political hit job all along now if he
wants anyone to take him seriously he
better get a different lawyer
foxnews.com breaking tonight they have
uncovered a series of tweets from the
fake whistleblowers attorney this guy's
name is Mark Z and make no mistake that
downright disturbing in terms of the now
it's now obvious that this lawyer is
despicable deranged the Trump hater a
partisan hack plotting the president's
destruction starting just ten days after
he was inaugurated look at your screen
January 30th 2017
Zaid retweeting news about acting AG
Sally Yates getting fired look at this
captured hashtag coup has started first
of many steps
hashtag rebellion hashtag impeachment
will follow ultimately hashtag lawyers a
few months later July 1st 2017 tweeting
we will get rid of him and this country
strong enough to survive even him and
his supporters we have two more months
Zaid tweeting incessantly about
president Trump's impeachment
comparisons to Nixon tweets fantasizing
openly what it's going to be like when
the president's impeached and of course
there is even a tweet highlighting how
fake news CNN is going to help take
Trump down I predict CNN will play a key
role in President Trump not finishing
out his full term as president who has
started will get rid of them CNN will
play a key role this is the embodiment
of rage and hatred and unwillingness to
accept the election results psychosis
chunk Trump derangement syndrome this is
the so-called whistleblower non
whistleblower hearsay whistleblower
that's his lawyer we're honestly
supposed to believe that the
whistleblower just had the best interest
in the country of mine no by the way and
it's time to start putting him under
oath put the compromised coward corrupt
Schiff
himself under oath Biden needs to go
under both under oath both of them and
that means hunter and Joe oh you get the
billion dollars if you fire the guy in
six hours you don't get the billion if
you don't fire them